frau wagenknecht sie verfolgen ja auch
den krieg sehr genau welche rolle hat
für sie lenski bislang gespielt und ist
es inszenierung oder machte einen guten
job gut er ist präsident eines
überfallenen landes und natürlich nutzt
er alle möglichkeiten in der
öffentlichkeit auch gerade eben in
westlichen ländern dafür zu werben dass
ein land unterstützt wird das ist ja
super das ist ja sein job das ist auch
nachvollziehbar trotzdem finde ich
müssen wir immer wieder und auch bei
allem bewusstsein das ist wichtig ist
die ukraine zu unterstützen vor allem
auch humanitär auch diplomatisch zu
unterstützen natürlich schon sehen die
ukraine hat auch interessen die nicht
unsere interessen sind also ukrainisches
interesse ist es natürlich die nato
immer mehr in den krieg zu ziehen weil
das ja ihre chance erheblich erhöht
diesen krieg zu gewinnen aber das kann
nicht unser interesse sein weil das ist
natürlich für uns eine wahnsinnig
gefährliche strategie und deswegen
glaube ich muss man da auch immer noch
unterscheiden also wir sind er macht das
für sein land und das ist ja auch völlig
legitim und völlig okay aber trotzdem
haben wir hier auch noch
unterschiedliche interessen und ich muss
sagen ich finde schon bedauerlich also
ich habe wahrgenommen dass er zum
beispiel in istanbul als da in
verhandlungen ja am laufen waren da gab
es ja einen vorstoß von ukrainischer
seite bestimmte kompromisse zu machen
und wenn man das durchgehalten hätte
hätte man den krieg vielleicht schon
beenden können ich weiß es nicht aber
diese wurden dann wieder zurückgenommen
und aktuell gibt es ja faktisch gar
keinen keine grundlage für verhandlungen
und ehrlich gesagt ist mir die strategie
nicht klar also zu sagen wir wollen
jetzt russland militärisch besiegen als
ukraine russland ist eine atommacht und
das russland sozusagen sich komplett
geschlagen gibt komplett die ukraine
verlässt ohne alle militärischen karten
ausgereizt zu haben das sehe ich nicht
und deswegen glaube ich kann der krieg
nur durch ein kompromiss beendet werden
der kompromiss darf nicht sein dass die
ukraine ein russisches protektorat wird
das ist ja kein kompromiss das wäre ja
eine unterwerfung aber es wird meines
erachtens auch nicht darauf hinauslaufen
dass russland irgendwann sagt okay wir
gehen jetzt hier raus wir räumen alles
und ihr habt den krieg gewonnen weil was
da vorher passieren würde das wäre so
wirklich dass man das meines erachtens
nicht riskieren darf aber fangen wir
haben doch schon erlebt dass es
funktionieren kann dass russische
truppen sich zurückziehen nämlich in
kiew das ursprüngliche ziel von wladimir
putin war die hauptstadt einzunehmen und
durch militärische stärke durch
westliche waffen durch kluge militär
strategie in kiew hat man es geschafft
dass die russischen soldaten nicht in
die hauptstadt gekommen sind jetzt geht
es um den osten und auch da ich war
letzte woche noch vor ort im don was
sagen mir dort die militärs und auch die
soldaten dass sie imstande sind sich
dort zu verteidigen und dass sie sich
auch imstande führen bestimmte besetzte
gebiete zurückzuerobern im don was und
da ist doch die klare frage wenn sie
sagen die ukraine hätten einen
kompromiss nicht möglich gemacht die
tatsache ist doch dass wladimir putin
sich dagegen sperrt mit lautem residenz
geht's überhaupt zu sprechen es gab ja
verhandlungen also nicht zwischen putin
und sie lenski aber zwischen russischer
seite und ukrainischer seite das war ja
ein ganz wichtiger weg und man hat ja
dort so ein korridor ausgehandelt und
sie haben ja in einem punkt recht ich
glaube schon dass die russische führung
am anfang ein ganz anderes andere
vorstellungen davon hatte wie dieser
krieg laufen wird also offensichtlich
warten sie die vorstellung wir gehen da
rein und nach sechs tagen sind wenn kiew
diese vorstellung ist gescheitert also
das war ist komplett war eine völlige
verkennung der realität sie haben dann
ihre positionen umgruppiert aber es ist
ja nicht so dass sie jetzt ich meine sie
haben ja schon langsam aber doch eben
mühsam ist die südflanke erheblich
besetzt sie haben don was einiges
besetzt und sie werden dort nicht
einfach so mal wieder abziehen sie haben
ja noch ein immenses
potenzial sie haben enorme ressourcen
sie haben auch noch viel schlimmere
waffen als bisher eingesetzt wurden und
bevor sie dort abziehen werden sie
sicherlich das was sie militärisch
können auch zum einsatz bringen und die
frage ist wollen wir das und was
passiert vor allem wenn das immer mehr
eskaliert also wenn immer mehr waffen
dann auch der nato eingesetzt werden
wird auch putin brutalere waffen
einsetzen und sie haben ja vorhin zu
recht gesagt und das ja auch der kollege
der gestorben ist ich mache jeden tag
sterben frauen sterben kinder wenn man
eine möglichkeit hätte mit einem
kompromiss diesen krieg zu beenden
wie viele tausende hunderttausende
menschen leben würde das retten und ich
persönlich kenne auch mir schreiben
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer die zum
beispiel jetzt in deutschland sind die
haben mir geschrieben dass sie wirklich
alles sich sehnlichst wünschen dass der
krieg endet weil ihre männer sind dort
die können auch nicht raus und sie haben
eine wahnsinnige angst dass sie
irgendwann eingezogen werden kämpfen
müssen und fallen und das sind dann
junge männer familienväter das ist doch
schrecklich das muss man doch beenden